hola buenas tardes alivio aquí en
bruselas han sido muy rápidos y veloces
las reacciones aquí desde la capital
comunitaria el primero en felicitar a
manuel macro no ha sido el primer
ministro de bélgica de bélgica a decoro
alexander de croo quien ha felicitado la
cooperación entre los dos países y la
importancia de que manuel macro no sea
elegido para una europa más fuerte y es
que está la fortaleza de europa ha sido
uno de los mensajes que también han
repetido los presidentes del consejo
europeo charles michel que ha pedido que
estos cinco años europa puede estar más
tranquila con emanuel al macro al frente
también la presenta la comisión europea
os la a vanderlei en que se ha
felicitado por continuar la excelente
cooperación porque juntos europa y
francia seguirán a cooperando también la
presencia del parlamento europeo
roberta med sola quien ha dicho que
europa necesita a una francia fuerte
para que europa también siga siendo
fuerte son las primeras reacciones de
los líderes europeos aquí desde bruselas
se respira con alivio había mucha
preocupación pero sí es cierto que como
estamos viendo los resultados marine le
pen ha aumentado su
apoyo entre los electores franceses así
que habrá que pensar ya que puede pasar
en los próximos cinco años en la extrema
derecha llegará alguna vez a presidir
también a francia y por lo tanto también
participará en francia estará dentro de
la unión europea con un país de con una
presidencia de la extrema derecha